abone ol
Bu
[Alkış]
da bizim için de arkadaşlık dostluk o
[Müzik]
o
zaman şimdi bakalım da
geçmiş
sosyal medyada bir Amos duydum ben suyu
Aslan
savaşıyor ve
devam ediyor şu önce bir şaşırdım yani
gerçekten o o benim tanıdığım Aslanlar
gibi burayı boyayacağız olabilir miydi
öğrendim ki doğruymuş
hemen al
[Müzik]
bir dizi daha varmış Bu arkadaşıma hemen
sonra hastane odasında yukarıya çıkıp
Yücel ve eşi Emine ile beraber çok
yıllar geçmişti biz onlarla hiç
karşılaşmamıştır sarıldık birbirimize
sonrasında yücel'e sordum yani hikaye
Sonra
sonra
[Müzik]
olması gerekiyor ve bu içinde çok
miktarda
Onun yanında böyle
[Müzik]
Merak etme o
[Alkış]
[Müzik]
Evet
şimdi şey yapmadım yaşatmak içindir yani
sırada olacağını yalan yalan değil Mühim
tanıtan bir onunla ilgili Yücel kimdir
diye bir sürü şey hazırladım ve tabi ton
basit verme koşullarını anlatamam Çünkü
herkes böyle gibi patlatılması çalan
veremiyor
Evet bunu sosyal medyada paylaşmaya
başladı arkadaşlar Dediğim gibi şu an
paylaşım bunu Çünkü biz seni daha çok
kitleye ulaşırsak bu şu insan olacak
paylaşmaya başladı her
zaman
arayabilir miyiz
bilirsiniz ne zaman isterseniz 7/24
arayabilirsin bir
o işleri üç kere falan böyle konuşmalara
başladık konuşmalarımızın hepsi Kahraman
bahsetmişti Hastanede hemşire falan
böyle ultrasonu düşürücü şeyler onu
niye bunları konuşuyoruz ya bunlar var
doğru kenarda Dursun ama aynı zamanda da
bir
geçmişi bahsedelim biraz işlerim
bulunması başladım
değiştirecek
[Müzik]
Beni takip et
Evet şimdi ilerliyorum hızlı yapı bölüm
Ne yaptın canım
hayır zamanda bütün
arkadaşlarını tekme arkadaşlar
eğlenceli böyle
yılında kutlarken böyle Sizler yaptık
gittik veya Kendim evde yemek yaparken
üye olarak ona bağlandı mı
[Müzik]
çok
güzel
ve
ruhlar şahaneydi hastane şampuanı indi
ve arkasında yani Yücel ve inanılmaz
mutlu Lady sokak arkasında garip bir
kişi oldu vardır fakat bir soru yaşam
savaşı Ya
kaybettik
3'er
2014 Ağustos ayında bu hayata veda etti
çok güzeldi konuşmamız sırasında
şöyle birşey değerlendireceğiz
başlayacağım hiç yazmıyorsun ya
bu ya o
bu
Yücel Tamam yapacağım söz bütün bunları
kitap yapacağım al sen Bro bu savaşı
yazacaksın bana söz vereceksin bu savaşı
kazanacaksın ben Burhan Felek Spor
Salonu'nda bütün senin için olması
çillerine bütün arkadaşlarını
toplayacağım sana dün gibi bir şeyler
yapacağım Besen o gün bize kanseri nasıl
yendi anlatacaksın aynı zamanda bu
istediğimiz alacaksın o zaman şimdi
böyle bir gülümseme olmuştu gece LOL
birimiz ağlayamadım Ben o kitabı
onun ölümünden vefatından aylar sonra
yani biraz daha toparlayıcı ona verdim
Siz tuttum yaptım
ailesi ve
bu inanamam sosyal olduk Tabii ki güzel
beraber uyuyacağım Savaşı'nın içinde
Yüce adlı kitapla beraber ölümsüz oldu
aynı zamanda o yaşam savaşında Onunla
beraber birlikte olan arkadaşları da o
gönüllüler ordusu oturması için ileri de
ölümsüz oldu
Yarın
beraber
Şifa
[Müzik]
göstermiştir 2015 Ocak ayında Şule aldım
üstü goleybol Şule abla bir fotoğraf
koydum teyzesinin ediyorum küçük boylu
bir yöneticiydi hatırlıyorum Şimdi
sordu Dedi ki
gerçektir ya boşuna abla dedim Yani
biraz oturuyoruz
bu kadın hiç gelen bu aslında kendi
Nasıl olsa fazla gelmiş olduk şimdi
Mesleğiniz karakterimiz çok tanıdığımızı
sandığımız olur insanlar
nasıl birileri vardınız bulaşıkları
vardı bu düşünceden yola çıkarak Böyle
bir eski ve aşığı kaç tabir vardı anca
bu döndüm dedim ki Aaa mücadele
duruşum vefat etmiş şu oraya kolumuzdan
geçen insanlar bizi tanısında Sen çocuk
gibi ay şifresini bir fotoğraf
araştırmak insanlarda tanıyorsun
merak ediyorum yapamam
ama ben
başla
dolaşmıştı
yani çok az
o yüzden yani Birkaç tanesini böyle
biliyorum Onların ve ailelerinin falan
şekilde ulaşabilirim şimdiden insan
bilinenlerden başlayın bilmezlere doğru
devam
eden başladım
Diğerlerine karıştırmaya başlıyoruz
[Müzik]
gibi
ipuçlarına ulaşarak
insanları bu dünyadan göçmüş bitmiş
buraya boncuğu
ailelerinin
tuşları var
fotoğraflar güzel
o
zamanın bayramıdır bu düşündü ama işin
düşer bir gün geçer ya kenara açılırsın
orada unutulmuştu biz unutmadık ve
88 tane vefat eden
kişi tanıdık o arada ve mi onların
ailelerinden onların torunlarından
çocuklarından öyle bir akım vardır ki
öyle güzel bir şey yani
Uyum sağladım Yani hiçbir şey değişmez o
sizin için onlardan gelen ben havuç
dedim ya Oha
dedim
büyüklerden biraz böyle sesler
yükselmeye başladı Yani
biz ne olacağız
takımlarda oynadım görmemiz gerekiyor
Yani hayatımızı yazmak için üçüncü geldi
bu tek hergün birisini tanınmış
Tamam ya o
ayrı bir şey yapıyorsun dedim ben yardım
ederim bu arada hep Bunların hepsi başla
sana gönüllü ve Aslında buraya gelebilir
Vefa Borcu işini değer mi oluşturan ve
bu aldık ve bilgi
gençlik çıkmadılar
ses çıkmadı kimseden dedim ki ya Bunu
yapılmalı yaşayanlarda hak ediyorlar
anılmayı
yağmuru
yapmadım ama bu güzel tamam mı uçsuz
bucaksız
olmalı 2015 tanesi 1965'de olgularda son
sınırlı ve
bütün Bununla ilgili
birinci kaliteli koyduktan sonra diğer
eserleri
bu açmasını açtım herkesi günü söyledi
şuna karar verdik en az beş yıl önce
Türkiye deplasmanlı ne ya da Türkiye
şampiyonlukları final yanında yer alan
takımlarda oynamak liderlik yapmak ya da
kendime olarak maçlara çıkmak yani
Aslında buradaki şey biter devamlılık ve
detaylı ve başladım
bir şey her gün her sabah nereye
gideceğim yani
[Müzik]
yavaş
9 530 530 yıllık bir
durumlardan başladık sonrasında 10'ar
yıllık
periyotlarla 136 bin 935 46 55 56 65y
devam ettim dedim Kitap yapmalıyım ya da
bir yanlışlık olmalı bu yani çünkü
geleceğimiz bu aktarmamız lazım dizisi
ne yazık ki mı gidiyorsunuz böyle
arşivlik veya içmiş geleceğe aktarmak
gibi bir durum yok İnsanlar bir dönemi
yaşıyorlar o dönem Eğer bu adamla
beraber gitmişsin bilmiyor ondan sonrası
o dönemde ne olur ne olur
[Müzik]
hayalin Işıl
Ben Boğaz Köprüsü yapacağım ve bu hafta
dedi
voleybolcular derneğine Bu Aslı bir
yaptıktan sonra şartlı olarak bu
ulaşacağım şartım ve canım daha büyük
şarkı birinde
bu uyuyalım
[Müzik]
bu
Hey
Nasılsınız bakalım bilmiyorum Hayır bu
farkında değildim sizin haberiniz
boyundan çok büyük İşte aslında
yapmak zorunda ki seviyordum ki Çünkü
insanlardan bana atan bir bir şeyleri
ben bunu yapmak zor dedim Dedim yani
hiçbir şey geçiyorum yani gerekiyorsa
kurumsuz yanında hiçbir şey olmadan
hiçbir şey olmasa bile Bak şimdi
satacağım sancağımızı yapacağım o kadar
böyle bir şey olacağını fark etseydin
Korkardım yapamadım Çünkü altı Tabii
için dört buçuk yıl Yani bu çalışmada
olmuştur buçuk yazıyor yine 218 sayfa
5 çift içinde oğlum birden fazla görsel
olan on sekiz buçuk Bu bir tosuncuk
için hiçbir reklam sayfası yok şimdi
ulaşacak ve karşı çıktım
çünkü reklam sayfası olan kitaplar ve
diğer Ben artık bir şey de buraya bunu
unutmaz larının şeyi dolu dolu ve
doktora onlar olmalıdır tasarımı ve
eritiyorum bu tam bir yıldız
bir şey yok istiyorsanız karşınızda iyi
insanlar çıkıyor bu da çok iyi anlıyorum
yani takdir misiniz zaman bir karşılık
olarak ucu bir şey demedin zaman
iki çocuğu
tasarımcısı Matbaası Bunlar kafasına Ya
aslında benim karşıma hayatta
çıkmışlardı Onlar burada aynı benim gibi
amatör bir ruhla ve dini büyükyakalı bir
Avcısı olarak satılır
çok güzelsin o benden daha gitti hiç
oluştu bugün çok Şimdi elime aldım
birincisi
şaşkındım eritiyorum ücretin dedi ki
bizde de böyle bir ansiklopedi 30
farkında
Ben gülümsedim
çıkmıştı ve ağzından çıkmışlar bunu bir
geri dönüşü yoktu ve
herkese aittir voleybol unutulmazları
Biz takımlar Bu sadece 18 coşkusu tek
başına kutlanılacak bir şey diyeceğim
Şimdi Yücel'i Hani söz vermiştin ya
Burhan Felek de bir düğün şey yapacağım
dedim ki Burhan Felek yüzyıllar boyu o
top oynarken tarafı tacımızı sonunda Biz
buldun mu Evet
Ee Salonu
sandalyeleri müzik sistemi ve sahneyi
sağolsun
federasyon
Destek verdin fakat Onun dışındaki her
şey her şey dev afişlerden plaketleri
yaka kartlarından Pier çalışmasına
her şeyde Her şey
bir avuç psikolog gönüllü Arkadaşım
benimle beraber olan yanın o kişiyi
geçmez o kadar küçük ve aynı zamanda
gönüllüler ordusuyla gündüzler kafasıyla
yapıldı satış yıldız generasyon var
bizim
sahanın Yıllar
yıllar boyu
yine attınız
olmaya kayıtları
bugün gerçek
ha ha pislikleri oluru hakikatleri
aşığım Allah filmlerde aileleri vardı
sporcularımız vardığımız yeni sorular
vardı Daha Güzeliz vardım şeyler yiyeyim
de
sağ ol dışında Türkiye'nin her birinden
hata Almanya'da gibi severim Tamam
sağdan fason bile Hadi oğlum yazılışı
yerler sağ olsun ben inanılmaz bir
kucaklaşma
gençlik yıllarında
30 yılında beraber top oynadı insanlarla
buluşmalarda yüzün vardı hepsinin
hesabını vardı
diyor Şu an
Evet yanlış şarjı bitti o gün göreceksin
koltuğun altına alan askerler
şehri
evine götürdüm fakat
bu şöyle bir şey düşünmüştüm
dedim ki bu çok önemli bir arşiv
çalışması şüphemiz evi yok Türkiye'de ve
dünyada dünyadaki araştırdım Çünkü aynı
branşlarında böyle kapsamlı bir benzeri
çalışma yok Ve üstelik düşünün ki bunu
bitti Bunu yapmıyorsunuz
bireysel
Evet mm var ama hepsi gönüllü ve seninle
beraber uzun paylaşmaya gelen
dedim ki davul kalıcı oldu Bizden
sonrakilere kalın olmalı evimizde Evet
var mı bittikten sonra onu unutmayın
çoluğumuz çocuğumuz sorununuz belki
patlayacak o zaman nereye gitmeli bu
akademisyenler öğretmenlere öğrencilere
örnek olmalı O zaman şu an o
Allah kullarına girmeli bundan taa
Yıllar Sonra da onun araştırma
yapabilirsin çıkarıp önüne koymalı ve
bundan yararlanmalı
Haziran 2027 bir avuç yine böyle bir
kedisi çık almıştık biz böyle ekip
olarak Ben inatçı onlarda bahaneler yer
açın diye bir kampanya başlattık
önce kendimizi Çünkü önce kendin olman
lazım kendini örnek olman lazım yiyor
renkler arkasından peşine bir örnekleri
de
takip ettirir onlar da bir şeyler gelir
Çünkü önce Biz başladık kütüphaneleri
aşkı bedenlerimizi bağışlamaya kızarması
için babası için kimse arkası için kendi
için boşluk
Arkadaşlarınızı aynı zamanda bu duyarlı
insanlarda Deniz oldu onlar da başladı
arkadaşlarınız
ne alakası mesleklerden alakasız spor
branşlarından bir biliyoruz bende Şurayı
Oğlum ben de babam için bana vefat
etmişti o oradaydı O burada kalsın
isimli diye ve
şu an rahatlıkla öderiz
1462 tane
kütüphanede kütüphane arşivinde
bireysel kurumsuz tek de
bana bir cesaret geldi dedim ki dünyanın
en büyük kütüphanelerinde yazıldı ama
Yok yavrum şu anda Amerika'dan meksikaya
Şilan Japonya'ya Fransa'ya İngiltere'ye
Yunanistan'a Hollanda'ya
her t'ye
çok büyük
[Müzik]
bir hayaldi ama
gerçekleşmiş oldu peki bu o alışır
kimler yani onlar yani duymadığımız
insanlar var mı işlerinde Ben onların bu
bu hareketin bulayım bir parçası
olduğuna inandığım için onların Hayat
hikayelerini onları sularken aktarırken
göre anlatmaya başladım
712 sembolik bir rakam
712 kişi Emeğe saygı 712 de soracağım
şimdi diyeceksiniz ki Tamam gülmüş Yani
o kadar çok konuştum ki dijital böyle
bunun içinde olur peki Ne yapıyorsun
işten oraya bu sen bunu aldım bağışladım
ne durumda iş üstünde
hayalim çok daha büyüdü
Bu araştırmaları merkezi ve voleybol
unutulmazları dijital voleybol Müzesi
olarak
ismini daha büyüktür benimle beraber 4
Akademisi yani arkadaşım ben gibi
gönüllü olarak ve onların öğrencileri
içerik çalışmasına araştırmalara
başladık kapsamlı zor yağsız edilen şey
ama aslında hiçbir
hepsi
yapılamaz görünüyorum evet
hadi Hayaller
o Hayaller her düşünceye görüştük
bu hayalmi düşünce
birleştir zamana İşte gördüğünüz gibi
bir gerçek olduk ve şunu demek istiyorum
aslında biz bunu yaptık
khet herkes yapabilir Sizlerde
yapabilirsiniz beni dinlediğiniz için
çok teşekkür ederim de